okay now
i'm trying to give you different
examples ones that will draw out
different kinds of
little traps or interesting things here
um
i love this question because it shows us
how mathematically you can understand
something with actually a very simple
mask
which is totally counterintuitive okay
let me talk you through it
here's a ladder okay and it's leaning
against the wall
um but it's a i don't know it's a
slippery wet day or something like that
and so the end of the ladder
this end the one that's on the ground is
sliding
it's sliding at a rate of four meters a
second it's actually very fast but
anyway
okay uh and the ladder itself is 10
meters long
very few seconds okay
it's just rocketing by okay now
10 minutes a second my question is
at what rate is you know this is moving
along the ground i said four meters a
second
at what rate is the top of the ladder
sliding down the wall
okay now by the way difference between
um you know
maths and physics i'm not going to talk
about forces like gravity
or um you know like damping or friction
or those kinds of things i'm just like
it's full
just deal with it okay now here's what i
mean by
simple question simple numbers
um and simple functions but very
counterintuitive everything in my brain
says if this is going at four meters
second
and it's constant
surely this is also going at four meters
a second
and it's constant i mean doesn't that
make sense to you or even if it's not
four meters a second surely it would be
if this is moving at
a constant rate and you know this 10
meters is constant
then this is also dropping the constant
rate right
i don't know that's just what i like
i've looked i've stated this question
for a while i've even done all the
numbers on it and i still look and think
but how does that even work okay
so let's actually have a go at this and
see if we can solve it
um like i said let me say the question
again this is sliding at four meters a
second
i'm interested in how fast this end
is sliding when let's see
when it's six meters away from the wall
okay six meters
okay at that particular time when it's
six meters away
how quick is it dropping okay how quick
is it dropping
so how should we start this what are we
going to do
time it watch the ladder and see how it
goes okay
what kind of information do i know from
the question
what rates am i given
so i've got you're like i've got d like
d what okay so we need to actually
introduce some variables in here
let's be unoriginal and um and call this
distance
the distance away from the wall okay
let's call that x meters
okay please note the difference by the
way between
this six and the x right the six is
a particular value for x x can change i
assume at some point x might have been
zero
what's the domain for x it has a domain
it can't just go anywhere
it'd be zero to ten right because once
it goes splat um
it's ten is the furthest away you can go
right unless it's
it's it's a self-animating ladder that
just runs okay anyway
so x right now i'm also asking like the
question is
how is this thing dropping so what would
you suggest is a good variable breathing
i suppose you could put y because it is
vertical um i'm going to put h
for height because it's it's high
so there's h okay
so therefore that uh sorry this rate
that we've been given a crossways
is distance over time right so this is
the x on dt
okay that's for four meters a second
this
rate here is the change in the height so
it would be
d h on dt that's what i'm after
okay i forgot to put a right angle in
here okay now
i'm after dx on dt um
so by chain rule right i'm going to
expect a dx on something
times something on dt okay and then you
look at
uh sorry wrong way around i i know x
i want h let's try that again h
h is that okay yes fixed up
um now if that's what i'm trying to
solve and the information given to me
in terms of dx only t you look at this
and think okay there must be
an x here and that means to get chamber
working there must be an x
there okay so i know this part it's 4
so i want to work out this
h x there's a relationship between the
two
what kind
h and x okay so so h and x
they're two sides of a right angle
triangle right so i can say
um h squared plus x squared is equal to
10 squared
because of pythagoras
now uh this is an unusual one because
you know
i don't have to get dx on the h i can
actually go straight to d h on the x
by getting this function in the form
that i want it and it's
h or x it's just as easy okay so if i've
got
h on the top and x on the bottom okay
usually when you say d y on dx right
you've got y
equals blah blah blah so this thing on
top that y
was the subject so i want h as the
subject
you tracking with me is that okay so
let's make h the subject
h squared is 100 minus x squared
right and so i can just take the
positive value because
it's a length
okay sorry h is greater than zero um i
actually can say more than that i can
say it's less than 10 as well
because that's how tall the ladder is
because not an anti-gravity ladder i
assume because if you had an integral
ladder why would you even need it to be
10 meters but anyway
there's my h so now i can work out dh
and dx
now this is chain rule this is 100 minus
x squared all to the power of a
half okay so hmm do you reckon you could
do in your head
then we can do this we can take this guy
okay let's have a go
it's the power of a half right so what's
the first thing you do
bring the half down so i'll multiply it
by half okay
and then the next thing you do is reduce
the power by one
so it's going to be 100 minus x squared
to the power of
minus a half okay so that that square
root is going to go on the bottom of the
fraction in a second
and then what multiply by
the derivative of the inside which in
this case is negative 2x
okay so you can see this 2 and this half
will cancel and that should really be on
the denominator
so i'm going to get minus x all over
this okay all right so now that i've got
my dh on the x i can come over here
and substitute into my chain rule part
right that's the h on dx i just worked
it out dx and dt
is just four okay so when i put them
together i get this
okay so hold on a second let's just stop
one of the great things about questions
like this when you're doing calculus is
that these things have meaning
right this is this is how the height is
changing
and it's decreasing because the height
is dropping sorry the height is dropping
the high is decreasing because the
ladder is dropping okay
now at this point this is where i want
to draw out the um the
counter-intuitiveness
of this result okay because you can run
it through 100 times this is the
derivative okay
this is not constant the way this is
constant
in fact it's not even close to constant
right as x approaches
10 as x approaches 10 think about what's
happening to this
as x approaches 10 what's the
denominator sorry what's the numerator
approaching
it's approaching negative 40. right
as this is approaching by the way why do
i have to say approaching why can't i
just say 10.
because i divide by zero good thank you
now as it's approaching 10 what's
happening to the denominator
it's getting really tiny right because
100 minus like 99 100 minus 99.9 etc
denominator is sort of an average number
but the new sorry
numerator is like an average number but
the denominator is getting
microscopic so as x approaches
10 which is where it can end right
d h on dt is approaching
negative infinity isn't it it's negative
because of that right
this is not even i can tell you because
i went and graphed it because i was
curious
um if you've got x equals 10 here
and you're graphing it with respect to
height this thing looks like this
it's dropping right it's not constant
it's not like
four okay so
i don't know if that if that satisfies
you it's like well obviously it must be
okay
um some of you guys are going to get
like a ruler against the wall in a
second and give it a go
but i still find this result very very
puzzling okay it's true but
i don't understand why exactly
um well hmm
why why should this be accelerating
which it is when this isn't
how can one accelerate the other anyway
uh there is a there's an answer to that
but i'm just gonna let it sit now i
wanted this at a particular
position right what position did i want
it
when x is equal to six so the last part
is just
pop it in okay so when x is equal to
six that derivative will be let's see
minus 24
on the square root of 100 minus 36
which is 64. so that's minus 24
on 8 which is minus
okay so it's it's dropping at a rate of
three meters per second so you would
answer that
um the the wall end of the ladder
at the top of the ladder that would be a
nice way to say it is
and instead of saying negative three i'm
going to say it's descending or dropping
at so the dropping gives me the
direction you see
at three meters per second
when x proceeds